and speaking of use of force continues
to be a focus on police reform
here and across the country metro police
and community leaders spoke today about
the work they're doing together
the i-team's david charns is live
outside of metro headquarters with more
on that david
well denise the chauvin trial obviously
highlighting a lot of these issues
across the country right here in the
valley and right here
inside metro headquarters the sheriff's
multicultural advisory council they meet
every month to talk about issues
involving race culture and policing
and they called a press conference today
to talk about the work metro is already
doing
to make sure what happened in
minneapolis does not happen here
members of this group pointed to metro's
work on de-escalation use of force and
other
training to make a difference in what
these officers do every day
and the sheriff tells me these
conversations they need to continue
you can't do anything when you have
somebody down with their face in the
concrete
you can't talk they're going to listen
they're going to hear anything that you
have to say
and you have to call medical attention
and so we worked on those things we
worked really hard on those things
we're trying to teach the officers to
look at it from a different paradigm
to slow down remove the emotion from the
equation
and get an understanding of the
situation before you rush in and
that's going to take a little while to
change
of course las vegas saw those riots and
protests following george floyd's death
almost a year ago now and with this
trial underway and a verdict
sometime soon speakers today say
they hope for peace and calm in the days
and weeks ahead
live outside metro police headquarters
i'm david charns 8 news now